the figure above shows a string with one
end attached to an oscillator
and the other end attached to a block
there's our block the string passes over
a massless pulley that turns with
negligible friction there's our massless
pulley with that turns with negligible
friction
four such strings a b c and d are set up
side by side as shown in the figure in
the diagram below so this is a top view
you can see oscillator this is the top
view of the oscillator string pulley
mass system and we have four of them
each oscillator is adjusted to vibrate
the string at its fundamental frequency
f so let's think about what it i'll keep
reading but then we'll think about what
fundamental frequency means
the distance between each oscillator and
the pulley l is the same so the length
between the oscillator and the pulley is
the same and the mass of each block is
the same so the mass is what's providing
the tension in the string however the
fundamental frequency of each string is
different so let's just first of all
think about what the fundamental
frequency is and then let's think about
what makes them different so the
fundamental frequency one way you could
think about it is it's the lowest
frequency that is going to produce a
standing wave in your string
so it's the low it's the frequency that
produces a standing wave that looks like
this
it's a standing wave
where the string
is half a wavelength
this is
i guess there's two ways to think about
it's the lowest frequency where you
could produce a standing wave or it's
the frequency at which you're producing
the
wave the standing wave with the longest
wavelength
so the string at the fundamental
frequency is just going to go is going
to vibrate between those two positions
and you see here that
that the that the wavelength here is
twice the length of the string and if
you wanted to see that a little bit
clearer if i were to continue with this
wave i would have to go another length
of the string in order to complete in
order to complete
one wavelength or another way to think
about it you're going up down and then
you're going down back it's it's
reflecting back off of this end here
and as we mentioned essentially what the
the mass is doing is providing the
tension the force of gravity on this
mass is providing the tension in this
string so the oscillator is vibrating at
the right frequency to produce this the
lowest frequency where you can produce
this standing wave
so let's answer the questions now
and we have four of these setups and
they all have different fundamental
frequencies
the equation for the velocity v of a
wave on a string is v is equal to the
square root of the tension of the string
divided by the mass of the string
divided by the length of the string
where f sub t is the tension of the
string and m divided by l is the mass
per unit length linear mass density of
the string
and hopefully this makes sense it makes
sense that it's going to be that if if
the tension increases that your velocity
will increase the tension you can think
of the the atoms of the string of of how
much they're pulling on each other and
so if the if if there's higher tension
well they're going to be able to move
each other better i guess you could say
accelerate each other better as as the
as the wave goes through the string it
also makes sense that the larger the
mass if you hold everything else equal
that you're gonna have a slower velocity
mass is under it's it's a it's you could
view it as a measure of inertia it's how
hard is it to accelerate something so if
those if the string itself especially
the the mass per unit length if there's
a lot of mass per unit length
actually let me circle that because
that's actually the more interesting
thing if there's a lot of mass per unit
length it makes sense that for a given
amount of of the string it's going to be
harder to accelerate it back and forth
as you vibrate it and so you this this
part right over here would be inversely
related to the velocity it's not
proportional though you have this square
root here but they're definitely if the
if the linear mass density increases
then you're going to have a slower
velocity and if your tension increases
you're going to have a higher velocity
so hopefully this makes some intuitive
sense
and they ask what is the difference
about the fourth string shown above that
would result in having different
fundamental frequencies explain how you
arrive at your answer and then part b a
student graph frequency is a function of
the inverse of the linear mass density
will the graph be linear explain how you
arrived at your answer all right let's
let's answer each of these
so a
part a what is different about the four
strings because they all have different
fundamental frequencies so the
fundamental frequency
let's just go back to what we know about
waves that the velocity of the wave is
equal to
the frequency
times
the wavelength of the wave
or you could say you could divide both
sides by lambda you could say that the
frequency of a wave is equal to the
velocity
over the velocity over the wavelength so
if we're talking about the fundamental
frequency
if we're talking about the fundamental
frequency
funda let me just
let me write frequency and then let me
write fundamental real straw small here
fundamental
the fundamental frequency is going to be
the velocity
of our waves divided by the wavelength
is going to be twice the length of our
string divided by 2 l and if you look at
the expression that they gave us for the
velocity of the wave on the string well
this is going to be equal to
the square root of the tension in the
string
divided by
divided by
the linear mass density divided by the
linear mass density and then all of that
is going to be over 2l
now all of them have different
fundamental frequencies but let's think
about what's different over here they
all have the same tension
they all have the same tension how do i
know that well what's causing the
tension is the mass is hanging over the
the pulleys so the weight of those
masses so that's all going to be the
same for all of them and they all have
the same length
they all have the same length
so these are all the same so the only
way that you're going to have different
fundamental frequencies is if you have
different masses
so different masses so that has to be
different
different
so what we can to answer their question
the strings must have different mass
well they would have different linear
mass densities but since they're all the
same length they would also have
different masses so let me write this
down
strings
strings
must
have
different
different masses
and mass densities
and mass
densities
densities
since
all
other
variables
driving
driving
fundamental frequency are the same
fundamental
frequency
are the same
are
the
same
all right let's tackle part b now
a student graphs frequency as a function
of the inverse of linear mass density
will the graph be linear explain how you
arrived at your answer so student graph
frequency let me write let me underline
this they're graphing
frequency as a function of linear mass
density
so we actually can write this down so if
we wanted to write frequency
as a function of linear mass density so
we could write as a function of m over l
well this is going to be equal to
it's going to be equal to well we could
rewrite this expression actually we
could just leave it like this this is
the same thing as 1 over 2 2l
times the square root of the tension
divided by the linear mass density
and or you could view this as being
equal to
you could say this is the square root
of the tension
over 2l and i'm putting all of this
separate because we're doing it as a
function of our linear mass density so
we can hope we can assume that all of
this is going to be a constant and then
times
the square root of
1 over the linear
mass density
so if you're if you're plotting if
you're plotting frequency as a function
of this
it's not going to be the graph is
definitely not going to be linear you
see here one i have the reciprocal of it
and then i take the square root of it so
so
so let me write this down
this
f of
a graph of f of 2l definitely not linear
let me write it that way
f of
m
over l graph
definitely
definitely
not
linear
and we could you could point out that it
has a reciprocal and it's a square root
involves
involves
square root
and
and
inverse or i could say and reciprocal of
the variable
and reciprocal
reciprocal of
the linear mass density of m over l so
definitely not linear all right let's
tackle part c
the frequency of the oscillator
connected to string d is change so that
the string vibrates in its second
harmonic
on the side view of string d below mark
and label the points on the string that
have the greatest average vertical speed
so one way to think about the
fundamental frequency that's our first
harmonic so if they're talking about the
first harmonic and the str and the
string is what i what i showed before
that's that's the
that's the lowest frequency that
produces a standing wave or it's the
frequency that produces the largest
standing wave i guess you'd say the one
with the largest wavelength and if it
was the first harmonic the parts that
the part of the string that moves the
most is going to be that center but our
second harmonic is the next highest
frequency that produces a standing wave
and that's going to be a situation
in which the wave instead of having a
wavelength twice the length of the
string is going to have a wavelength
equal to the length of the string so now
it's going to
look like this
so it's going to vibrate between
this actually let me draw a little bit
neater than that
it's going to vibrate
between
between this
and
so
it's going to vibrate between that and
this
and this right over here
so when you see this this version of it
where now that we have half the
wavelength the wavelength is exactly the
wavelength of of it's actually l this
time the part that moves the most are is
here so that's going to move the most
and here i didn't draw it perfectly
but one way to think about it's exactly
1 4 and 3 4 of the way exactly halfway
is not going to move as much it's not
going to move because it's a standing
wave now or it's going to move very
imperceptibly these two places where
you're going to move the most at the
first sorry at the second harmonic the
second harmonic being
the next highest frequency that produces
a standing wave again